wird sich deutschland abschotten wegen
der virus mutation prüft die
bundesregierung offenbar die grenzen
stärker zu kontrollieren und den
flugverkehr auf nahe null
herunterzufahren druck auf astrazeneca
nach den angekündigten
lieferverzögerungen diskutiert die eu
über exportbeschränkungen für impfstoffe
und streit um plug-in-hybride ein teil
des elektro booms ist eine mogelpackung
sagt eine umweltstudie
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und in allen hier ist
dieser dienstag im nachrichtenüberblick
und der sportliche teil davon nachher
mit kristin otto schuster freude bei uns
kommt es gibt einen leichten rückgang
bei den infektionen mit corona in
deutschland es gibt forderungen dass
sein fahrplan her muss auch für
lockerungen und es gibt die sorge vor
dem was uns bevorstehen könnte wenn die
mutierten varianten in deutschland
flächendeckend um sich greifen
das ist der hintergrund vor dem in der
bundesregierung offenbar darüber
diskutiert wird den flugverkehr in
deutschland fast komplett herunter zu
fahren
auf nahezu null wie der innenminister in
der bild zeitung zitiert wird
anselm stern fasst zusammen deutschlands
reise durch die virus krise extrem wenig
los am größten airport in frankfurt
heute nachmittag die zahl der
neuinfektionen im land sie singt sehr
deutlich und doch sollen die panini
maßnahmen wohl verschärft werden wegen
der mutation wächst die sorge bei denen
die entscheiden müssen die kanzlerin
warnt seit wochen heute beim virtuellen
weltwirtschaftsforum wenn man auf den
verlauf von infektionszahlen schaut und
das haben wir uns jetzt ja alle
angewöhnt dann ist ja sozusagen das
phänomen des exponentiellen wachstums so
dass sie am anfang wenig sehen und in
diesem in diesem zeitabschnitt bereits
zu handeln
das ist sozusagen die eine große lehre
aus der pandemie diese lehre so scheint
es könnte durchaus praktische konkrete
folgen haben für uns alle auf merkels
wunsch prüft der bundesinnenminister
ganz offenbar neue drastische
reisebeschränkungen
dazu gehören deutlich schärfere
grenzkontrollen besonders an den grenzen
zu hoch risikogebieten aber auch die
reduzierung des flugverkehrs nach
deutschland auf nahezu null
so wie israel das derzeit auch macht
keine deutschen flugverbindungen mehr
etwa nach großbritannien oder südafrika
die meinung von passagieren
ich arbeite internationalen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und wenn ich
nicht reisen kann kann ich auch nicht
arbeiten
also ich bin dagegen und ich halte das
für völlig übertrieben
ich kann es verstehen wenn es vielleicht
verschärft werden würde aber ob das
jetzt vielleicht für alle dann verein
gut getan ist schwer zu sagen denn die
mutierte ansteckende virus variante kann
nicht nur per flug sondern natürlich
auch per zug lkw oder auto ins land
kommen reisefreiheit als virus risiko
doch so mahnt die schwer gebeutelte
branche
diese freiheit sei eben auch ein
wichtiges grundrecht das offenbar große
sorge vor dem was die mutationen
anrichten könnten israel das seinen
einzigen großen flughafen dicht gemacht
hat gilt als vorbild jetzt ist eine
völlig andere geografische situation
natürlich theo koll in berlin kann sich
denn deutschland wirklich abkapseln von
der welt nein das ist natürlich eine
illusion die erfahrung dass das virus
nicht an grenzen haltmacht haben wir ja
schon gemacht
die virus mutation aber haben die lage
aus sicht der bundesregierung noch
einmal drastisch verändert es herrscht
die sorge dass jede durchreisende
eingeschleppte mutation eine mit großen
folgen ist in israel beispielsweise ist
die britische variante in kürzester zeit
zur dominanten form geworden daher sind
die pläne der bundesregierung zur
massiven einschränkungen des
reiseverkehrs offensichtlich auch
ausdrücklich die sogenannten
virusvarianten gebiete aufgenommen also
jene länder in denen die virus
mutationen schon vorherrschend sind das
ganze soll schon morgen im kabinett
besprochen werden
theo was geht da hinter den kulissen der
regierung vor die kanzlerin wird mit
dramatischen appellen zitiert aber auch
mit selbstkritik
ja die massiven mängel bei der
impfkampagne sind ja mittlerweile so
deutlich dass es an der zeit war für
selbstkritik contest ist ja nicht nur
das impf problem die pandemie hat
bestehende defizite schonungslos
offengelegt die mangelnde
digitalisierung der behörden der schulen
der bildungsföderalismus all das hat
deutschland in der pandemie bekämpfung
zurückgeworfen
übrigens hinter und auch vor allem vor
den kulissen hat die kanzlerin zudem ein
vermittlungsproblem die zahlen gehen
runter die forderungen nach
- perspektiven werden lauter die
menschen sind pandemie müde und
gleichzeitig steigt im kanzler und die
sorge vor den hoch ansteckenden
mutationen und damit steckt man im
dilemma weitere einschränkungen noch
nicht mit fakten belegen zu können
theo vielen dank für diese analyse der
zwickmühle in berlin und nicht nur in
berlin das einzige mittel gegen das
corona virus impfen schnell waren erste
impfstoffe verfügbar
dann ging alles plötzlich sehr langsam
und einer der impfstoff produzenten
astrazeneca kann oder will jetzt nicht
mehr wie vereinbart liefern
das erhöht den druck auf die politik
gerade in europa schauen wir auf die
impfzahlen das ist der weltweite blick
auf die lage mit großem abstand vorne
israel 44,8 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung haben hier bereits
mindestens eine spritze bekommen
in großbritannien sind es gut 10 prozent
in den usa rund 7 und deutschland etwa
zwei prozent es gibt viele alte und neue
fragen bei den verantwortlichen hier und
in europa mehr jetzt dazu von stefan
leifert und das virus zwingt auch der
davoser bergfeld eine woche ruhe auf und
die teilnehmer hinter
computerbildschirme die impfstoff
knappheit das thema heute band
virtuellen weltwirtschaftsforum europa
hat milliarden in die entwicklung des
corona impfstoffs investiert und damit
eine im wahrsten sinne globales
gemeingut geschaffen
und jetzt müssen die unternehmen liefern
sie müssen ihren verpflichtungen
nachkommen eine mahnung an astrazeneca
der britische impfstoff hersteller
produziert unter anderem hier in belgien
will nun aber der eu nur einen bruchteil
der vereinbarten menge liefern
großbritannien hingegen bekommt was es
bestellt hat in der eu werden nun
exportbeschränkungen diskutiert hier
geht es nicht um eu first hier geht's um
europe's verkehr also den fairen anteil
und deswegen macht aus meiner sicht ist
sinn dass wir eine exportbeschränkung
haben heißt also dass impfstoffe die die
europäische union verlassen
eine genehmigung brauchen damit wir
zumindest mal wissen
was in europa hergestellt wird auch in
deutschland produziert astrazeneca so
wie hier in einem partner werk bei
dessau
der ton zwischen eu und großbritannien
wird rauer
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir im
nationalismus und protektionismus jetzt
ablehnen denn wann immer dass versucht
wurde hat es am ende nicht nur dem land
geschadet dass es anwendet sondern auch
allen anderen ländern also weil er für
die impfstoff debatte dreht sich weiter
doch eins bleibt immer gleich der eu
zählen die impfdosen mit
exportbeschränkungen für die eu ihre
folterinstrumente vor anwenden möchte
brüssel sie möglichst nicht denn kurz
nachdem die exit beschwört die impfstoff
knappheit einen brisanten konflikt
zwischen eu und großbritannien heraus
was klar ist im kampf gegen die pandemie
wird noch enorm viel impfstoff gebraucht
neue anbieter sind da natürlich
willkommen
der us pharmariese johnson & johnson mit
seiner tochter jansen gilt als
vielversprechender kandidat das
unternehmen will seine klinischen
studien schon bald abgeschlossen haben
mit im boot ist das münchner klinikum
rechts der isar
dort wird der impfstoff an freiwilligen
getestet cornelia strauß diese
münchnerin ist eine von 100
studienteilnehmern die am klinikum
rechts der isar den möglichen neuen
impfstoff erhält der hoffnungsträger der
firma janssen ist ein sogenannter vector
impfstoff dass 90 prozent der geimpften
nach einer und 100 prozent der geimpften
nach zwei impfungen sogenannte
neutralisierende antikörper gebildet
hatten und diese neutralisieren beim
antikörper sind die grundvoraussetzungen
oben gegen koch 19 immun zu werden
denn zwei parallel laufenden studien mit
insgesamt 75.000 probanden weltweit wird
geprüft ob dieser impfstoffkandidat
zweimal oder möglicherweise nur ein mal
verabreicht werden muss ein weiterer
vorteil wäre dass er nur bei
kühlschranktemperatur aufbewahrt werden
kann
auch andere experten halten das für viel
versprechend denn die hier angewandte
technologie wird bereits erfolgreich im
kampf gegen ebola eingesetzt
ja es ist auch so dass nach einer dosis
bereits ein ordentlicher schutz da ist
und das ist halt sehr wichtig in so
akuten pandemie szenarien also da ist
natürlich seinem stoff zu haben der nur
eine dosis erfordert ein ungeheurer
vorteil
vereinfacht gesagt werden hier
adenoviren die erkältungen auslösen
können bestandteile des corona virus
eingepflanzt der körper entwickelt auf
die adenoviren eine abwehrreaktion dabei
wird das immunsystem auch gegen das
corona virus trainiert die probanden der
studie wissen nicht ob ihnen der
impfstoffkandidat oder ein placebo
gespritzt wird
die eu kommission hat bereits 200
millionen impfdosen bestellt wenn alles
läuft wie erwartet wird die firma im
februar bei den zuständigen behörden
eine zulassung beantragen können wir
haben es schon angesprochen in dieser
sendung die infektionszahlen sinken in
deutschland aber nach wie vor fordert
die pandemie sehr viele todesopfer
menschen die sich vor einiger zeit mit
dem virus infiziert haben
das robert koch institut meldet 6400
acht neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 4961 weniger als
vergangenen dienstag 9 103 menschen sind
in verbindung mit dem virus gestorben
und auch in nordbayern steht jetzt ein
ganzes klinikum unter quarantäne
mehr als 3000 krankenhausmitarbeiter in
bayreuth sind betroffen
in mindestens elf fällen gibt es den
verdacht auf eine infektion mit der
hochansteckenden virus mutation aus
großbritannien
das virus sei auf mehreren stationen
ausgebrochen
die beschäftigten dürfen sich nur noch
zu hause oder am arbeitsplatz aufhalten
nur einen absoluten notfällen werden
noch patienten aufgenommen
ein jahr corona in deutschland eine
riesenbelastung für die kliniken gleich
um halb acht spricht ein intensivpfleger
über seine erfahrungen und sie können
ihre fragen stellen hätte er heute live
über youtube facebook oder unsere zdf
heute
die korona krise wird viel geld
verschlingen sehr viel geld der staat
mit milliarden neuen schulden auf dafür
wurde die schuldenbremse ausgesetzt
das hat der bundestag wegen der akuten
notlage ausnahmsweise erlaubt doch auch
in den nächsten jahren solle das so
bleiben sagt jetzt ein spitzenpolitiker
der cdu kanzleramtsminister helge braun
löst damit in der union ein kleines
erdbeben aus er will eine
verfassungsänderung um auch in den
folgenden jahren neue staatsschulden zu
erlauben
die schuldenbremse hat seit 2011 die
staatsverschuldung deutlich gedrückt sie
verlangt einen ausgeglichenen haushalt
und begrenzt die aufnahme von krediten
kippt corona jetzt dieses prinzip und
was steckt hinter browns vorstoß aus
berlin mathis feldhoff
es wirkt wie ein veritables eigentor das
der kanzleramtsminister da seiner union
geschossen hat unter der überschrift
plant für deutschland schlägt brown eine
zeitweise kontrollierte aussetzung der
schuldenbremse vor
diese sei vorerst nicht einzuhalten
ob die kanzlerin informiert war ist
nicht bekannt angela merkel distanziert
sich heute es sei browns privatmeinung
lässt sie mitteilen
auch fraktion und partei reagieren kühl
und ablehnend schließlich wird braun an
einer der grundlagen der politik von cdu
und csu einer politik die man jahrelang
verteidigt hat wir haben ja übrigens für
solche pandemie fälle für fälle großer
katastrophen den artikel 115 genau die
ausnahme zeitlich befristet mit
rückzahlung und vielen vielen
einzelregelungen die wir jetzt auch auf
den weg gebracht haben in der pandemie
und wir glauben das ist absolut
ausreichend und insofern brauchen wir da
auch nicht mehr darüber zu diskutieren
die befürchtung in der union einmal
ausgesetzt kommen die schuldenbremse nie
wieder bei der fdp löste der vorgang nur
spott aus orientierungslos nennt fdp
chef lindner die christdemokraten
die position von herrn brown hat dagegen
den charakter einer finanzpolitischen
kapitulation geradezu demonstrativ
begrüßt er ist mit die kanzlerkandidat
scholz browns plan und auch die grünen
sind voll des lobes ich kann die
unionsfraktion nur auffordern nicht an
alten ideologischen dogmen festzuhalten
sondern da eine offene debatte
einzusteigen es ist der beifall von der
falschen seite am nachmittag relativiert
helge braun seinen vorschlag ich liebe
die schuldenbremse schreibt er auf
twitter
die krawalle wegen der nächtlichen
ausgangssperre in den niederlanden gehen
weiter die polizei berichtet von 184
festnahmen in haarlem rotterdam und mehr
als zehn anderen städten haben hunderte
jugendliche stundenlang randaliert
sie griffen polizeibeamte an plünderten
geschäfte und legten brände ein
millionenschaden
mindestens zehn polizisten wurden
verletzt jugendliche verabreden sich
offenbar über das internet sie stellen
dort auch videos über ihre taten ein
in italien nimmt die politische
unsicherheit zu und das mitten in der
korona krise regierungschef giuseppe
konnte ist zurückgetreten weil seine
koalition im parlament keine mehrheit
mehr hat
er bleibt aber erstmal geschäftsführend
im amt gegen mittag machte er sich auf
den weg zum staatspräsidenten konnte
hofft dass der präsident ihn erneut mit
der regierungsbildung beauftragt dann
könnte er nach neuen koalitionspartner
suchen
möglich sind aber auch neuwahlen das
fordern die rechten oppositionspartei
zurück nach deutschland
der gesamte landesverband der afg in
sachsen anhalt steht jetzt unter
beobachtung des verfassungsschutzes eine
solche beobachtung ist möglich wenn der
verfassungsschutz die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung in gefahr
sieht und ihm genügend anhaltspunkte
dafür vorliegen
die afg ist im landtag von
sachsen-anhalt größte oppositionspartei
wir ganz oder teilweise elektrisch auto
fährt in deutschland der kann sich über
reichlich staatliche zuschüsse freuen
das gilt für privatpersonen genauso wie
für unternehmen und bei den firmen
werden vor allem die plug in hybrid
modelle
beliebter also die kombination von
elektro- und verbrennungsmotor wurden
davon anfang des vergangenen jahres noch
gut 190.000 gewerblich genutzt so waren
es im oktober schon fast 330.000 ob die
bilanz für die umwelt genauso positiv
ist wie für den geldbeutel ist höchst
zweifelhaft wie dominik löschmeister
zeigt plug-in-hybride das sind autos die
kleinere strecken elektrisch fahren
können
eine studie im auftrag des
bundesumweltministeriums zeigt aber sie
sind weniger klimafreundlich als
angenommen
vor allem im täglichen betrieb läuft
mehr der verbrennungsmotor und das heißt
dass es schwieriger ist hohe elektrische
anteile in der praxis zu realisieren und
zum zweiten kommt dazu dass viele
dienstwagen nutzerinnen und nutzer von
ihrem arbeitgeber eine tankkarte
gestellt bekommen das heißt den sprit
müssen sie nicht bezahlen aber den strom
wenn sie zuhause laden müssen sie schon
bezahlen
dabei werden plug in hybride massiv
gefördert start und hersteller geben bis
zu 6000 750 euro hinzu dienstwagen
nutzer müssen den wagen statt mit einem
nur mit 0,5 prozent des
bruttolistenpreises versteuern
je nach kaufpreis und steuersatz sparen
dienstwagenfahrer damit steuern
plug-in-hybride eine mogelpackung die
industrie sieht das nicht so
hybride sind der ideale einstieg für
viele menschen ihnen das thema
elektromobilität die neue generation
ermöglicht dass man sich problemlos im
nahen umfeld zur arbeit familiär bewegen
kann und für längere strecken auch einen
modernen effizienten verbrenne hat mit
den plug-in-hybriden kann die industrie
ihre co2 bilanz verbessern auch wenn sie
in der realität wohl mehr ausstoßen die
verfasser der umweltstudie verlangen die
förderung zu überprüfen
so jetzt sport anfang der sendung hast
du uns frust und ich hab's mir
aufgeschrieben frust und freude
versprochen christine text zu einem guss
ist in der tat frustriert kern
deutschlands handballer von der wm in
ägypten zurück enttäuschend auch das 23
23 unentschieden gegen polen im letzten
bedeutungslosen spiel raus in der
hauptrunde das schlechteste abschneiden
in der wm geschichte
sie hatten vor der wm lautstark vom
olympischen gold geträumt und müssen
jetzt sogar um die qualifikation im märz
bangen
der letzte wm auftritt gegen polen reiht
sich ein in die serie enttäuschender
auftritte des deutschen teams das seinem
trainer im übertragenen sinn die haare
zu berge stehen lässt
in diesen paar minuten und 1 thomas
ernst völlig unverständlich dann auch
die eine deutsche auswahl den möglichen
sieg geradezu amateurhaft verspielt und
sich patricia andreas wolf bedanken
musste das unentschieden fest hält also
wenn man ehrlich ist mit einem
klassischen ausreichend zu mehr hat es
dann zu mehr hat es da nicht hat es da
nicht gereicht
in der deckung ist einfach ja sind wir
noch nicht so weit das muss man muss man
so sehen
so sehen muss man auch dass das einzig
auf steigende für das deutsche team in
ägypten die gangway hinauf zum rückflug
ist am ende einer dienstfahrt die man so
schnell wie möglich vergessen möchte
so und nun ist es amtlich thomas tuchel
hat einen neuen job wie erwartet als
teammanager des fc chelsea in der
premier league einen vertrag über 18
monate mit option auf verlängerung die
bestätigung kam erst vor wenigen minuten
raus aus dem abstiegskampf lautet das
ziel beim bundesligaverein hertha bsc
unter trainer-rückkehrer pal dardai der
sich ziemlich entspannt der neuen
herausforderung stellt bis 2019 war der
ungar schon mal viereinhalb jahre im amt
und zuletzt für hat das nachwuchs
zuständig das mit dem abstiegskampf
sieht er etwas anders stehen wir nicht
den abstieg platz ja ich fehler mache
sorge ich würde die wort das mal wäre
damit wir abstieg beim abstieg platz
habe und mit 373 einsätzen ist er
herthas bundesliga rekordspieler
jetzt soll dabei den tabellenvierzehnten
nach enttäuschenden wochen auf seine art
neu motivieren nacht macht so denkt so
das ist alles schön und positiv ich
hoffe irgendwann die krone ist vorbei
dann darf die zuschauer kommen und dann
kommen diese an dieser dieser restlichen
20 30 vielleicht einige 40 prozent dazu
der anfang wird schwer zuerst auswärts
in frankfurt und dann kommen die bayern
der vorfreude danke christin nach
heftigem schneefall besonders in bayern
wird es morgen ruhiger alle einzelheiten
gleich von katja horneffer ich empfehle
ihnen das heute journal mit der kollegin
bettina schausten 21 uhr 45 morgen freut
sich petra gerster an dieser stelle auf
sie
ich wünsche ihnen jetzt einen angenehmen
haben
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren heute gab
es ja massive schneefälle und
schneeverwehungen vor allen dingen in
thüringen und in bayern die lassen jetzt
nach denn das kleine schnee tief zieht
hier weiter nach südosten
dann beruhigt sich das wetter
vorübergehend mit dem hoch elke aber
schon bald kommt das nächste tief bringt
auch wieder regen schneeregen und schnee
mit und über dem atlantik lauern weitere
tiefs heute nacht also schneit es noch
hier in niederbayern und schon wieder
westlich des rheins im emsland ist auch
schneeregen dabei nach wie vor bleibt es
glatt auf den straßen
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus zwei
und minus sieben grad morgen liegen die
temperaturen meist knapp über dem
gefrierpunkt in den mittelgebirgen und
am alpenrand bleibt es dauerfrost ich
milder wird es am rhein und an der
nordsee
die größten chancen auf sonne haben sie
morgen im nordosten da kommt sie nämlich
mal zum vorschein
sonst aber fällt regen schneeregen und
schnee in der gesamten westhälfte und
das bei südwestwind und dann selbst von
südwesten massives tauwetter ein
es droht also hochwasser vor allen
dingen an den zuflüssen von mosel main
neckar und rhein und im nordosten ist es
sehr kalt und an der grenze zu dieser
frostluft droht in den nächsten tagen
immer glatteisregen schönen abend noch